まあ今日のテーマはこの常識と非常識という両方なんですが
まあ大体としてはまあ死んだ常識と生きた非常識というふうな
まあこれはまあちょっと面白くするためにまあ書いてるだけで
ただタイトルは常識と非常識って何なのかということなんです
そうすると面白くないんだからね
まあ一応こういう風にしてしまったんだけど
それで私はもう昨日困ったのは
あら これ何喋ればいいんですかと
何考えたんですかと で
まあで 結構悩みましたけど
それでまた思い出しまして
ああ これはタイトルは一応常識と非常識ということではなかったと
まあかなりボケてますからね
これはそうやって自分が思うことも後で忘れちゃいます
で  常識で非常識といえば
まあ大体この我々のこの仏教勉強会に集まる方々も
まあよく感じている非常識があるんじゃないかなと
で これ あの これはなかなかこの人が集めたら
この丁寧に挨拶をして始まらないんですね
まあいきなりいい加減もう好き勝手に始まったりする
私も形式的な挨拶で全然話が始まりませんね
もういきなり話を始まると
まあえらい非常識やなとね
皆様方は思っていた可能性あります
あるいはなんかちょっと馴染めないんだと
雰囲気が違うんだと まあこれ私も結構悩んでて
後でお願いしたんです
私の話が始まる前に せっかく集まっていただいている皆様方も
もう大変苦労して まあ忙しいなのに
こういう面白くない話を聞くためにね
来ていただくこと自体が大変ありがたいのではないかと
ですから そこら辺はちゃんと丁寧に挨拶を私の代わりにどなたかがしてくださいと
というふうに頼むことにもなりましたけど
で 私がしたってもいいんだけど
問題は日本語下手なんですね
ですから この常識的な挨拶は常識的な日本語でしなくちゃいけないんですね
それはちょっとまあ無理ですよ
私はいきなりこの自分の研究に必要な日本語だけ勉強したんであって
日常生活のことは知りません
結婚式にも行ったことがないし
葬式にも行ったことがないし
で だから日本の文化の中で生きている日本語っていうのは知らないんです
テキストの中の日本語以外はね
だから このわからないことをやって余計に怪我するよりは
わからないことはわからないことにした方が
私に対して 私に対してはその方が正しいと思っているんですね
できないことを偉そうにやってみようと
ということはやりたくないんです
そういうことで 皆様方にそこら辺はお願いしているんです
じゃあ仏教は非常識で
そんな挨拶なんかしないかと
だから私のやり方を見て
挨拶しないのかというと
そうでもないんです で
なぜ私は一言葉も喋れないで
いきなり では礼拝と参詣に行きましょうというのは
それは我々の常識なんです
それは挨拶なんです で
ここで何のために集まるかというと
釈迦牟尼ブッダの話を聞くために集まるんです
で そこでお釈迦様がいないんだから
まあそれを勉強している私はただ代表でというか
ただ話すだけであって
私も皆様方も一応お釈迦様の教えを何を教えてくれたんですかと聞くために来るんですね
ですから 常識っていうのは先生に礼をすること先なんです
学校に行ったら 学校の先生は玄関で土下座させて生徒に挨拶するということは
まあ私たちから見ればちょっとおかしいんですよ
生徒が先生に挨拶をして
よろしくお願いしますと言わなくちゃいけないんではないかと
ちょっと古臭い常識かもしれませんだけどね
今は逆に もしかすると現代時代で先生が土下座させて挨拶しなくちゃいけないと思っているかもしれませんだけどね
どうせ仏教っていうのは古いもんだからね
やっぱり目上の人に 先生に自分が教えてもらうんだから
挨拶するんだよと そういうことで
もうお釈迦様に対する礼
挨拶なんですね で 次に何で五戒文唱えるかというと
やっぱりお釈迦様から教えてもらうんだったらね
まあだらしない人間ではね
あんまり話にならないんですね
ですから 口先だけでも一応立派な人間で生きていきたいという努力ぐらいはいたしますと
そういう口先だけの約束でもした方がいいんじゃないかなということで
五戒を唱えるんですね
まあまあ それから日本には紹介する気持ちでね
慈悲の瞑想を実践しますけど
ですから 一般日本の社会から見れば
私のやり方はものすごい非常識で
突然いきなり何の前触れもなく説明もなく
じゃあ南無他施婆訶波多阿羅陀でいきましょうと
これ何なのかとみんな戸惑ったりするんですね
でも私から見れば 皆様方に挨拶する前に
みんなで一緒にお釈迦様に挨拶するべきではないかと
そこでそういうふうな問題が出てくるんですね
今日からそれを一応覚えておいてください
我々はお互いに挨拶する前に
もう我々一緒に まずお釈迦様に礼をして挨拶をして
それから人間同士で挨拶するということ
そういうふうなことで
いろんなところでこういうのは見えますけど
この常識でか非常識かどちらかわからない
なんか混乱する 戸惑う
戸惑うところはね まあいろいろ仏教の世界の中でも見えるかもしれません
そこで私が普通のやり方で考えちゃうと
いつでも私はする質問は
まあ皆様方は常識 非常識とはなんとなくわかっているような気がするでしょう
じゃあわかってますかと
常識って何でしょうか？と
非常識って何でしょうかと
まあ定義できますかと
この あ 私はわかってるんだよということは
仏教ではすごく危険だと思っちゃうんですね
あ 私はわかってるんだと
だって常識でしょ わかってるんだと
それ自体は危険ですよと
そう思うことは そういう風になっちゃうと
一向に頭が良くならないんですよ
ですから いつでも我々は頭のいい人間になりたければ
もうこれはいらんお世話かもしれませんだけど
やっぱりブッダの話を聞くならば
お釈迦様がやっぱりこのウィズダムという知恵
知恵っていうのはまあ知識のゴール点なんですよ
知識を乗り越えたところで知恵があるんですね
その知恵のために それを開発するために
教えてきたんですね なんで知恵がそんなにありがたいかというと
人間が知恵がないと 無知だったら
アホだったら バカだったら
頭が悪いんだったら どうにも幸せにはなりくはないんですね
逆に大変な危険なことをするんですね
不幸を作っちゃうんですね
ですから この幸福になりたければ知恵が必要ですね
それでお釈迦様は じゃあ知恵を開発する方法
知恵の上達する方法を教えてあげようと
ということで説法しているんですね
ですから この知恵開発するためには
この何だかんだも常識でわかっちゃうと困るんです
あ それぐらいのことわかってるんだと
ですから どんな言葉にしたっても
どういうものにしたっても
これは一体何ですかと
自分が本当にわかっているんですかと
自分で疑問した方が まあ知恵というものが生まれて開発してくるんですね
そういうことですから
まあ常識 まあそれぐらいのことをわかっているんだと
だって常識っていうのは常識でしょうと
常識が知ってることは常識でしょうと
というふうに思ったりすると
何もわかってないことになっちゃうんですね
それは一般的に我々はお分かりになっていないということを証明するために
私はちょっとしたエピソードを考えたんですね
例えば 人があの 何か変なことをする
何でもいいんですよ もう何か変なことをする
あるいはバスに乗って逆立ちしていると
まあそれ変なことでしょうね
そうすると 他の人はそういうことをするなと
座席が空いてるんだから座っていくのは常識ではないかと
そういうふうに言うかもしれません
そこで そこは一般的に言えば
まああんたやってることは非常識ですよと
我々はよく他を批判したことがあるんじゃないですか
躾をしたことがあるんじゃないんですか
それは常識じゃないんだと
非常識やと この非常識ですよという言葉自体は大変批判的な言葉なんです
あんたやってることは非常識ですよと
これはきつい言葉なんです
私たちはまあ なんとなく
あまりもう気が付かないで聞いてるだけなんですけど
そこでもしその人が一体常識って何ですかと
その人に聞けば答えられますかね
皆様にもそういう経験があるだろうと思いますけど
他の人にね あんたやってることは非常識ですよと
結構偉そうに言ったことがないんですかね
それで言われた側が逆に常識って何ですかと
聞かれたら答えられますかと
だからこのこのテーマをね
やっぱり発展させて持っていくためには
その定義が必要なんです
もし今でも皆様から意見を聞くと
もう何か答えるだろうと思います
常識って何ですかと そうすると
もし隣の人が言うこと
裁判みたいに証言取ってみたら
私は他の人みんなあっち行ってくださいと
一人一人に聞いて記録しちゃうとたくさん意見が出ると思います
みんなの前で聞いちゃうとダメなんですね
私はそれは日本の常識だと知ってるんだから
隣一人の人が私は常識ってそういうものだと思います
と言ったら 隣の人 私もそう思いますよと
それで意見一つで全部終わっちゃうんです
だからそういうやり方は私はもう即座に知ってるんだから
あまり意見聞かないんですよ
意見言ってくれないんです
聞いても誰かが一人の方はやっぱり親切な心優しい方が先に立って何か意見を述べるんです
それから次から次へと
まあ私も同じ意見ですよ
私も同じ意見ですよと
それで無知のままで人生終わっちゃうんです
あれはおかしいんです
人の意見はなんで自分の意見になるんですかね
何のことなく もうその同じ意見ですよと
時々よく私に聞こえることは
ある人が自分の意見を私に言うんです
それなぜ言うかというと
私の意見と違いますからね
で そこで何か意見を言って
これは日本でみんなそういうことを考えているんですかと
意見に私は全然怒りません
例えば あなたがやっていることはおかしいんですよと私に言われると
私は全然怒りません ああ
そうですかと それから一応話し合いしましょうというところで
日本のみんなそう思ってるんですよと
いきなりみんなそう思ってるんですよです
その一言葉で私はもう相手にしない
勝手にしなさいと お前阿呆やと
あんた言うこと聞かないんだと
と頑固になるんです なぜかというと
ある人から見れば 私の話し方やら生き方やらね
それはおかしいで変だよと
理解するのはそれはいいんです
それは何の悪いことでもないんです
それで日本でみんなそう思ってるよと言った途端
もう私は潰したくなっちゃうんです
その人 あれは嘘だから
はっきりした嘘だから
自分が腰抜けで逃げようとしているんです
で あまり追求して質問しませんだけど
どうせそういうふうに言う人が無知ということはわかってるんだから
あまりいじめませんだけど
そうと言っても話は無視しちゃうんですね
なぜかその人はアンケート取ったんですかね
日本国民の 国民のアンケート
あなたはどう思いますか？あなたはどう
そのアンケート取って
ところで  100%このやり方が悪いと決めたならば
みんなそう思ってるんですよと言ってもいいし
まあ散々そういうふうに言われてきたんですね
だからまあ そういうことでも知恵が出てこなくなっちゃうんですね
だから人の意見は自分の意見ではないし
自分の意見もまたかえって人の意見
ないんです そういうことだから常識っていうのはありますかね
世の中で 本当は それで話戻りますけど
あの これは非常識ですよという場合は
私たちには大体答えられなくなっちゃうんですね
何が常識ですかと もし答えたならば
その その人が言う通りにやると
またそれも非常識になっちゃうんですね
それで この常識の問題解決する前に
私たちには大きな疑問がありまして
私に常識って何でしょうかと
説明できますか？定義することはできますかと
その問題 私はあまり答え出したくないんですから
皆様方はそれは各自で
まあこれからの人生の役に立ちますからね
で 考えても悩んでみた方がいいんです
一体全体常識って何でしょうかと
じゃあまあ 次のポイントに行きます
定義しないで 常識って何ですかっていうことは全然説明しないで
だから説明するのは私の仕事だと思ってるでしょ？それは常識だと思ってるでしょ
説明しません   一つの常識の定義っていうのは
私から見ればね 自分に気に入らないものには平気で非常識と言うんです
自分に気に入らない 相手やってること
言ってること それで平気で非常識だと
言う場合があるんじゃないんですか？大体あなた非常識ですよという場合は
必ずしも自分にそれ気に入ってないんです
必ずしも気に入ってないんです
気に入ってるんだったら言わないで面白いよと言うんです
やってることは  話聞いたことがありますけど
日本でもいろんなところでみんな集めてパーティーとかやったりすると
みんなもうもう着ているものを全部脱いで
もう裸で踊ったりするんだそうですけど
見たことはないんだけど
それでみんなもう手を叩きながら喜んでいるんだと
あんな人の前に裸になることは常識ですか
どう見たっても非常識でしょうに
なんであの時非常識だと言わないんですかね
喜んでいるんだからなんです
そこで日本のサラリーマンの方々は
まあどうせ忘年会やらいろんなことをやっているとかね
酒飲んでもうどこかでもうやっていることはすべて全体的に非常識なことばっかりでしょうに
それでみんな喜んでいるんです
変な形をしたり 立派な大人なのに
自分の子供に見られたらいかに恥ずかしいかと
やってることはね それも考えないで
まあ平気で まあ会社のみんなと一緒に集まってそんなことやったりするでしょ
いろんなこと それも考えてみれば非常識なんですけど
その人は全然非常識やと言わないんですね
恥ずかしいことをやっているのに
ですから その場合はなんで非常識だと言わないんですかね
それはまあ喜んでいるんだからなんですね
気に入ってるんだからなんです
そういうわけで 人間の常識
非常識の定義そのものさえも
まあそんなに真剣 この知識的に
この まあ知恵を目指して物事を考える場合は意味がないんです
世の中の常識っていうのは
結局は自分に気に入らない
自分に気に入らないものは非常識だと言ってしまっちゃう
それでいいんでしょうか
定義見たら皆様はその問題わかるはずなんです
私は私に気に入らないものは非常識だと決めつけますよと言ったら
これ自体おかしいとわかるはずなんです
だから結局世の中では他人の機嫌を取って
もう他人の気持ちを計算しながら
生き生きることを考えること
しゃべること そこは常識だとと思っているんです
で そこから出てくる問題っていうのは
それだったら一向に人間には成長はありませんと
その常識守っちゃうと
だって 人の機嫌を計算しながら
人の機嫌を見ながら 相手に合わせて合わせて動くと
で 一箇所で止まるだけなんですね
それにあの お釈迦様の立派な例えがありますよ
これは何回も言いましたからね
で あの 目が見えない人々のあれ
あの和の話 目が見えない人が杖を持って歩くんだけど
もう前の人がその杖の先をつかまってるんですね
そうすると後ろに立ってる人が
前の人が杖捕まってるんだから
そのその通りに行けばいいんです
でも その前の人にも目が見えないんです
後ろの人の杖をつかまってる人にも目が見えないんです
その人も前の人の杖の先をつかまってるんですね
まあ手でもいいんですよ
目が見えない自分が前の人の手を握っている
前の人にも目が見えないんですから
その人ももっと前にいる人の手を握っていると
そこでどんどん手を握って握っていて
誰かが一番先にいる人の手を一番後ろの人の手につなげてあげると
それでみんな両手で一つの手を前に握っていて
後ろでもう後ろの人の手を握っていて
それで歩くでしょうに
どこまで歩けるんですかね
例えば 100人でもいいんですよ
目が見えない人で  100人でも前の人の手を握って歩いてくださいと言ったら
どこまで歩くんですかね
歩くことは確かに歩くんだけど
ずっと同じところで回るんですよ
同じところで回ってるということにさえ気がつかなくなっちゃうんですね
だから誰かが目が見える人が必要なんですね
先に進めたければ これ
常識の問題の場合も同じことで
私が他の人々の機嫌を好き嫌いを計算しながら行動したりする
そういう人々も 他の人々の好き嫌いを見ながら行動して
計算して行動していると
そうすると誰一人も 成長しなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば こちらに私が皆様の意見に合わせて
それは常識だと思っちゃうと
各皆様方も皆様の意見に合わせるのは常識だと思っちゃうでしょうに
だから一人一人の人が自分があまり知らないという状態でいて
みんなまとめたっても知らない結果になってしまうし
ですから そういうふうな人の機嫌を取るということ
人に合わせて生活するということも
論理的に考えると もう社会というのは
人類というのは 1箇所に止まってもらう
1箇所にこの泥の沼で腐れ腐るようなものなんですね
だから大変なことなんです
はい  そこは一応今日の話のこのメインテーマでもあって
それはもう一応結論なんです
常識というものはそんなもんだよと
あの ただ相手の機嫌を計らうぐらいのことなんですよ
で 決まりがないんです
結局は そこで気に入られる場合は
どんな変なものでも認めるんです
常識だと 会社でちゃんと背広を着て
ネクタイをつけてかっこよくいて
夜もう飲み屋さんに行ったら
まあほとんど裸で遊んだりしたりして
とんでもないみっともないことをしたりして
それまた常識なんですね
だからあまり当てにならないんですよ
常識という人が言うことはね
そこは一応結論として置いておいて
だといっても 一般論としては
我々はなんとなく全然わかってないのに
やっぱり世の中の常識を守るべきですよと
常識ですよと それぐらいのことを常識ですよと
というふうな この土台はしっかりしていないんです
何言ってるかと本人もわかってないんです
で 一応浮いてる言葉ですけどね
その浮いてる言葉使ってるんです
どんな人に聞いても 常識
それはもう常識だからね
守るべきですよと 常識は破るなと
常識常識を犯すな 犯すなと
それぐらいのことは当たり前ではないか
当たり前ということも常識という意味ですからね
あれ 何なんでしょうかと
で 常識ですよ 常識ですよと言うんだけど
一人も何が常識だとわかってないんです
頭の中でしっかり理解していないんです
こういうこういう項目は常識でありますよと
だから浮いてるんですよ
言葉が 意味なしに それをお釈迦様はすごい注意している言葉なんですね
言葉には重みがなくてはならないんです
重みというのはミーニングですね
意味ですね 意味っていうのは自分の大変な大事なことなんです
自分の経験で証明しているものなんです
例えば今日は寒いですよっていうのは浮いてる言葉でもないんです
今日はという言葉自体浮いてるわけじゃないんです
我々は何かは理解するんです
今日はといえば寒いですよと言ったら何か理解するんです
何か何とか理解するんです
例えばこの話は面白くないですよって言ったら
ああ それはその通りだと何か理解しているんですね
ですから 喋る言葉には何か重みがないと浮いてしまっちゃうんです
そうやって宇宙に何のもあてもなく
何のコントロールなく浮く言葉っていうのは
無駄無駄な言葉であって
智慧がなくなる言葉であって
何の刺激もないんです
脳細胞に 時間のロスで時間の無駄なんです
それでその言葉の中で一つなんです
この常識という言葉が
他のこと 例えば現在日本の経済状況は悪いですよと言ったら
なんとなく重みがあるんです
でも私はそれも浮いてると思いますけど
私はどうしても性格が悪いんだからね
そんなこと言ってます
あれは浮いてるんだと
なぜ私はそういう言葉にさえ浮いているんだと言うんですかというと
比べて言ってくださいと
例えば年 去年でもいいんで
1985年と比べると 2000年の経済状況は悪いですと言ったら全然浮いてないんです
そうするとちゃんと重みがあって
ちゃんと根付いてるんです
言葉が だからみんなこの景気が不景気は不景気だと言うんですけど
あれ言葉が浮いてるんですよ
だから この不景気の何とかして景気の方に変えることはできないんですよ
なぜできないかと 不景気だと言うんだけど
分かってないんです 何が不景気ですかと
単なる浮いてる言葉が
だから この我々生きている社会で
そうやって大量に我々は言葉を喋ってますけど
ほとんど浮いてるんですね
浮いてるんだから いろんなトラブルが起こす
全てこの常識の問題です
よく考えちゃうと常識だと思っちゃうんです
例えば不景気ですよと言ったら
みんなまあそうですねと
常識でそれに納得するんですね
だから不景気といえば
見たら悪い言葉でしょ
不景気ですね だから幸せですと誰も言いません
だからね 不景気ですね
まあまあ大変ですねという結果ですからね
だから不景気です 不景気ですともう言うだけであって
じゃあどうすればいいんですか？どうすればその悪い状況を破れますか？という知恵が出てこない
なぜ出てこないかというと
あの言葉には意味がなかったんだからなんです
だから この世の中でいろんなトラブルについて我々は喋りますけど
誰一人もすばりと答え出せないんですね
どんな問題すると じゃあ子供たちの問題であろうか
教育の問題であろうか
現代若者の問題である
いろんなことについてしゃべる
しゃべる しゃべる でも誰もしっかりした道
こういう風にすればいいんじゃないかということを頭に出てこないんです
理由はすべてこの常識でしゃべることと
言葉自体が浮いているんだということなんです
だから見てください いきなりお釈迦様の世界っていうのは
もうちょっと見ただけで大変な世界なんですね
大変な修行を必要するんですね
喋る時でも浮いてる言葉が喋れないようにしてしまうと
そこで人間に一生 でも生きる道
道が見えてくるんです
大人いうことをなんで子供が聞かないかとかね
なんで学校の先生言うことは子供たちが聞かないかというと
すべての言葉が浮いてるんです
あんた方しっかりしなさいよと言ったら
浮いてるんだから 子供たちはわからないんですよ
しっかりしなさい 何ですかね
あれは 正直にわからないんです
おとなしくしなさいよと言っても
あれ どういう意味ですかね
だから子供はどうやって自分の生き方直ればいいんですかね
正せばいいんですかね
なんで大人が平気でそうやって浮いてる言葉を言うんですかね
そういう大人っていうのはみんなそうなんですよ
政治家から総理大臣からホームレスの方々まで
よく説教したりするんだけど
すべて仏教で喋ってはいけないという無駄話
言葉が浮いている 意味がない
だから浮いてる言葉にはもう反論もできるし
もう反論もしたりするし
そういうことで この常識というところで我々はかなりやられているんです
いろんな言葉が浮いてるんだということをわからないのは
この常識の問題に引っかかってるんだから
不景気ですと言った途端
常識ですよと思っちゃうでしょ
そんな浮いてる言葉で常識だと思ったら困るんです
不景気だとしたっても
日本のすべての仕事の世界
不景気であるわけでもないんです
結構うまくいっているところとものすごいやるんですね
で うまくいってないところもある
倒産するところもあって
どんどん巨大化になって力強くなる組織もある
それなのに何のことなくまとめて不景気だとと言ったりする
私はすごく心配したことがありまして
大蔵大臣などなど この大変責任を持たなくちゃいけない人々の話を聞いちゃうと
あんまりにも浮いてるんですね
あんまりにも言葉を浮いてるんですね
ああ これだったら危険もものすごい
もう大変だなと すごい大変なんですよ
大蔵大臣だろうが 誰か何か喋ると
まあその浮いてることも喋れないで
こういうポイントで こういうことでこういうことですよ
ちゃんと言わないと まあまあ
そこでこの言葉にやっぱり本当に意味があってほしい
常識といっても それにもちゃんと意味があってほしい
意味があると道があるんです
ですから で 子供たちにね
まあおとなしくしなさいよというんじゃなくて
まああまり大きな声出さないでくださいね
言ったら子供たちわかるでしょ？あまり大きな声出さないでくださいねと
で 昔 私はこのお寺で法事やってた時は
まあえっと ものすごい人が集まって
そこで子供たちいっぱい集めて
子供たちは法事はもう興味ないんだから遊びに来る
それで遊びたい放題遊ぶ
大人の人々が真剣真面目にまあお経をあげたり
いろんなことをやったりする
それで いくら我々大人が声出して喋ったっても
子供たちの声には負けちゃう
で うるさい だからみんな苛立ちをする
だからって子供たちを追い出すわけにもいきませんし
お寺というのはオープンなところだから
誰が来たってもまあ断ることもできないし
で 私が時々大人が怒るんですよ
怒ったり怒鳴ったりする
でも子供は聞かない で
私はある日 こう考えたんですね
このグループが集めているんで
とにかくこのガキのグループが
もうもうもう一寸法無茶苦茶遊んではるぞと
で そちらにとっても この大人が集めて真剣に何かやるところで遊んだ方が気持ちいいんですね
しょうがないんです 自分の親たちやらおじいちゃんたちやら
みんな集まって真剣勝負に何か仕事に引っかかってる
そこで自分たちが気持ちよく安心して遊ぶ
それだけのことなんです
でもかえって もう法事やら説法やら何一つもできない
で 私はその子供たちの集まっているところに行って
一応リーダーみたいな一番悪ガキに悪ガキを呼んでね
一言葉言ったんですね
この法事終わるまでちょっと助けてちょうだいねと
法事終わるまでちょっと助けてちょうだいよと
それだけど 子供は理解したんです
何を言ったかと それで不思議なことには
ものすごい人の話を聞かない悪ガキなグループでしたけど
法事にも1時間半ぐらいかかりますし 1
時間半ぐらい全然声がないんです
聞こえないんです ちゃんとおとなしく
そこでさっさと自分たちで声出さなくても何か遊び事がないかと違う遊びを考えて遊んでいたんですけど
その遊びには声は要りません
キャーキャーと泣かなくてもいいんです
だからあんた方は静かにしなさいと
もうもうお釈迦様の前で今起き上げたり
大事なことをするんだからね
何です あなた そんな風に言ったっても
言葉自体が浮いてますね
だから子供たち悪いんじゃなくて
子供たちがわからないんです
どうすればいいんですかと
そういうことですから
この  そういうケースいくらでも言えますけど
言葉だけ浮いてないとかなりうまくいくんですね
だから問題があって 答えがある
問題があって 答えがあると
ですから 常識っていうのは守るべきか破るべきかというと
答えがないんですよ 浮いてるんだから
だから常識って何なのかとちゃんと意味をつけたところで
破るべきか守るべきかということを言えるんです
そこで私が一応重みの重みというか
意味のある ちょっとした重り過ぎてる常識についてちょっと喋りたいんですけど
世の中で一般的に皆様方も誰でも常識という言葉を使ってますけど
そこに本当にあるのは
この我々の平和的な生き方
互いに邪魔をしないで
自分自分の生き方 幸せで平和で生きるために必要な行動やら言動やら
そういうものは常識なんです
社会の秩序と呼ぶんですか
この社会の状況 秩序を守られるような我々の生き方が常識であります
そうやって意味をつけてあげてください
社会の法律 平和を守られる
自分には自分なりの自分の仕事をして
それで何の問題もなく生きていられる
自分なりの幸せをつかまれる
他人の幸せを壊そうとはしない
平和を破ろうとはしない
そのような生き方自体があるべき
常識なんです ですから
これは非常識ですよと言ったところで
相手の人が常識って何なのかというと
いえ みんなに迷惑にならないように
みんなに邪魔にならないように生きることが常識であると
他を困らせることが非常識であって
他が困らないようにすることは常識ですよと
今あなたがやっていることによってみんな困っているんだと
みんなに迷惑ですよと
だから非常識ですよと
そこを言ったらみんなちゃんと理解して守ってくれますよ
例えば 小学生の子供たちなんかはね
まあ電車に乗ってすり変わりますね
あっちにぶら下がっていることは
ぶら下がってブランコみたいな感じで
それは決して非常識ではありません
でも そこでお母さんたちは座っていて
他の人々は座っていて
立っていて ちょっと人がいっぱいいるんですね
いるところで 子供は小さいんだから
何のことなくどこにも行けるし
そこで上飛んですり皿捕まってもうブランコにしちゃうと非常識なんです
電車に人がいなくて ただもう何人かがあっちこっちの側が座っているだけで
もう通路の方がいっぱい空いていて
そこで子供たちがちょっと逆立ちしたっても
もうそんなことは非常識ではありません
わかりますか？同じ行動なんですけど
ある時は常識で ある時は非常識
基準はどこにあるかというと
人がいっぱいいると これは困りますね
まあ人がいないんだったら
どうぞやってくださいと
で それぐらいのことなんですね
だからそういう理解あるならば
ちゃんと我々にもう何のことなく
社会はうまく平和的に
社会に平和的にいられるように指導することというかね
まあそれはできるようになるんですね
子供は大きな声でしゃべることは
まあ子供だからしょうがないよと言うのは非常識で
ではなくて まあ今はもういい
大きな声出しちゃっても
でもこの時はダメですよと
その子供たちに正しい常識をちゃんと教えなければいけないんですね
だから これ私の定義なんですけど
私の定義といっても この世の中であるべき定義なんですね
社会の平和を守る 社会の発展に邪魔しない
他人に迷惑をかけない生き方自体が常識であって
そうでない生き方は非常識なんです
ですから 人を殺すことは非常識でしょう
泥棒することも非常識でしょう
女性の方々を犯したり
いろんな悪いことをするの
これ非常識でしょ なぜ非常識ですかね
ちゃんと意味があるんですよ
迷惑だから 迷惑だからそれは非常識なんです
だから挨拶するのは常識ですよとか
そういう風に決めてほしくないんです
挨拶した方がいい場合もあるし
別にしなくたってもいいんじゃないかっていう時もありますからね
だから挨拶しないことは
相手に対して失礼で迷惑であるならば
必ずともしなくちゃいけないんですね
時々挨拶しない方が 相手にとって大変気持ちのいいいいことになる場合は
それはそれでもよろしいし
で 子供が学校から帰ると随分機嫌が悪いと
そうすると ただいまというところをいきなり部屋玄関開けて
もう全部投げつけちゃってて
自分の部屋に行ったりする
それであんた常識破るなと
常識でちゃんとダメで言いなさいとかね
そう言わなくたってもいいんですよ
その時は その時は違うことを考えた方がいいんですね
放っておいた方がいいかもしれませんしね
だから常識 非常識というのは
そうやって人のためになるかならないかという基準で考えなくてはならないんですね
そういうことだから 一応世の中には常識というものがあるんです
みんなわかってないだけでトラブルを起こすだけ
だから私に言えるのは
常識にほんのちょっと定義を入れてみてください
その定義も好き勝手な定義ではなくて
お釈迦様がおっしゃった定義
皆様のみんなのために
みんなの幸せのために
みんなの幸福のために
すべての生命が仲良く
これ それぞれの各自の幸せのために生きることが生きる目的
目的でもないんだけど
生きるときのみんなの
まあそれ モットーそれですから
それを守ることは常識であって
破ることは非常識ですよ
で だから昔も今も人を殺すことは非常識だと
これからも人を殺すことは非常識だとまあ言うでしょう
嘘を言うことは非常識だと
良くないんだと これからもそういう同じことでいくでしょうと思いますけどね
で まあそれぐらいのことで
そこで次に起きてくる問題は
みんなに迷惑をかけなかったらいいでしょという開き直り
それはどうすればいいんですかね
自分が自分好きなことをやっているんだと
みんなに迷惑ないんだからね
うん まあその場合は皆様方どういうふうな答えでよろしいと思いますか？ある人が好き勝手なことをやっていて
それ一言言ったら もうあんたに迷惑はないでしょ
他の人に迷惑がないでしょ
だから放っておいてくださいと
なぜならば みんなに迷惑をかけることは非常識であって
迷惑をかけないでやることは常識ですからと
まあ私個人的な意見も
私もその場合は放っておいた方がいいんじゃないかなと
本当にみんなに迷惑でないならば
放っておきましょうと
別に気にしない方がいいんですね
その人が自分で好きだからやっているんですけどね
一応大体放っておいた方がいいんです
それは 100%そういうわけではないんだけどもね
まあその中でそういうのはやっぱりケースバイケースでいろいろ具体的にケース
見て考えていかなくちゃいけない
例えば人が誰にも迷惑ないんだからといって
自分が麻薬使っていると
そういう激しいケースで考えないとね
はっきり言えば 一人が自分勝手に麻薬を使って
私が好きだからやってるんだと
私はあなた方には何の迷惑もかけないんだとと言えるならば
放っておいた方がいいんだよ
死ぬのはその人だからね
時々私は思いますよ 時々ね
なんで日本の警察いちいち麻薬なんか調べるんですかと
ある個人が自分使いたい
使いたいんだから使っているんであって
放っておいたってもいいじゃない
人の自由でしょうと思う時もありますよ
あれ 決して警察は人間の幸せを思ってやっていることじゃないんです
もし法律で個人個人が健康的でいるべきですよと
個人の健康は侵すなと
みんなしっかりした知識人で生活するべきですよという法律があるならば素晴らしいんだけど
そういう法律はないんです
あれあれ お金で考えて
麻薬をやっちゃうとかなりお金が動くんですね
1円も税金は払わないんですね
でも 酒なんか飲んで酔っ払ってどうなったって
いっぱい税金入りますからね
だから酒飲むのはよろしい
タバコ吸うのもよろしい
いっぱい吸ってください
麻薬は使うなと 結局 基本考え方が税金もらわないんだからなんです
だからそういうのはそんなありがたい法律ではないんですよ
ありがたい法律というならば
各人が健康でいるべきですよと
しっかりした知識で生きるべきですよと
だらしない生活をするべきではありませんと
それで個人が個人の健康を失うことをするならば
法律違反ですよと というと
私が好きだからって毒を飲んだり
麻薬を使ったりすることはできないんです
法律を犯してるんです
本当は法律 そういう風に変えた方がもっと作用するんですよ
もっと作用するんです
ある人がテレビで見たんだけど
公園であっちこっち車で寝てる人が
警察がいきなり来て突然調べちゃうんですね
あんた何やってるんですか？とか言ったら
その人はもうただそちらで寝たりしているだけですよ
ったら 調べをすると 私はやましいこと何もやってないんだったらいいでしょうと言ったら
警察 まあまあ それはそうですけど
だからそれはその人の考え方
でも警察の人々から見れば
これ暑いのにもう長袖の服とか着ているんですね
それであんた なんで暑いのにこんなこと着てるんですか？と
ちょっと手を見せてくださいと言ったら
もう蚊とかいるんだから
こういう風にやってますよと
ちょっとちょっと見せてくださいと言ったら
あっちこち傷跡あるんですね
これは何ですか？と 蚊にやられちゃったんだと
で いいながら 私は何かやましいことをやってないんだったらいいでしょうと
また開き直っちゃうんだけど
そこで警察は車の中を調べて
下下ちょっと調べてもいいでしょうか？とか言って調べたところで
針やらね 見つかっちゃうんですね
見つかると まあこれもちゃんと写真撮って
ちゃんとテレビでもやってるんだだからちゃんと法律に従ってやってましたけどね
じゃあこれじゃあんた見てくださいとね
じゃあこれ写真撮りますよと言って
写真も撮って それをこれから調べますよと
これは麻薬ですよと そういうことであなたは逮捕しますということで逮捕しましたけど
私から見れば その人は自分勝手に麻薬使っていて
そこで車の中で死んじゃってもね
それはその人の勝手だからね
放っておいてもいいんじゃないかなという気持ちも坊主なくせに思うんですよ
だからなんでそう思っちゃいますか？だから法律自体がおかしいんですね
だから酒飲んで歩きよになったっても
同じ健康の害でしょうに
そういう人々にはすごい親切で
酒飲んでも別に法律違反じゃないんです
酒飲んで車を運転したならば
法律違反なんですね それも事故を起こしても起こさなくても法律違反であって
で その場合はみんなに迷惑ですよとかね
ちゃんと運転できないんですよということで
やるならば ヤクザったっても人を起こしたりとかね
悪いことをしなかったりするんだったら
まあ放っておいたってもいいんじゃないかなということをしますけど
だから私はそんなことを言いたくはないんだけど
言いたいのは法律自体がおかしいということなんですね
法律は人間のために作るんだったら
個人の幸せを 個人個人の幸せをちゃんと認めて
それを守るために作らなくちゃいけないんですね
でも 法律はものすごいいい加減で
何のために作っているのかわからない法律はいっぱいありますね
だから人が法律どうしても破りたくなっちゃうんですね
で 自分のために作っている法律はだいたいどんな人でも破りません
だから 例えばヤクザの人々でも車に乗って行くでしょうに
赤信号ついたら止まりますよ
人が渡るとちゃんと車止まって待ってますよ
そういう人々も 法律守ってるんです
で なぜかというと これは自分たちのためにある大事な法律だから
行って他のところで犯したりする
そういう他のところで法律を犯したりするところも
やっぱり法律自体がしっかりしてないんですね
だから法律の世界でよく見えることは
この弱い者いじめなんですね
弱い者は平気でいじめられるように法律を作る
だからこの悪い人を捕まるようにとあるんだけど
あんまりそう考えないんです
力強い人はうまく逃げるようにと
アメリカの法律そういうのよく聞くんだけど
もう金さえあればね 金さえあればうまく逃げられますね
裁判で ですから それはもう人のためということはそれほど考えてないんですね
ですから まあこれは私は仏教の話しか喋ってるんだから
皆様の常識とはどうせどうせ違うと思いますけどね
これはお釈迦様の常識なんですね
だから決まりつける場合は
もう万人の幸福を考えなくちゃいけない
万人といったっても 地球でみんなの他の生命
みんなを一緒にいないと幸せで生きていられないんですね
微生物いなかったら我々生きていられないでしょうに
ですから 微生物までみんなも元気で健康で生きていてほしいと
そうするとお互い様でみんな幸せですよと
そこは常識であって でもその常識
みんな破ってるでしょうに
だから仏教は非常識なこと
この坊主言うというんじゃなくて
私は逆を言いたいんです
世の中の人々は誰一人も常識守ってない
みんな非常識もいいところだと
と言いたいんですけどね
結局は だから何を見たっても人をいじめることはある
いろんな言い訳する 例えば国のためにというかっこいい言葉あるでしょ
今はあまり使ってないんだけど
日本では 昔は使っていたんだからね
国のために かっこいい言葉やと
国のためだと思って なんで他の国の人は死ななくちゃいけないんですか
隣の国には関係ないでしょうに
自分の国のためだったら
自分の国のために頑張ってくださいと
だから国のためにという言葉
それは常識ですよと それを破っちゃうのは非国民ですよとか言いながら
それで軍隊に強引に人を捕まえて
他の国の人を殺すために送っちゃうんです
ああいうのは常識ですかね
で この間インターネットでちょっと仏教のホームページいろいろ探っているんだからね
まあで 一つのホームページを見たところで
私は驚いちゃったんですね
ちょっと記事があって
ワンライフフォーワンスリーパーというちょっとした記事があって
他の記事とはあまり関係なかったんで
それは あのスリーパーっていうのは枕木ですかね
線路に使うあれ 枕木 英語でスリーパーと言うんです
あの寝てる人という意味じゃないんですけど
スリーパーといえば スリープって寝ることで
スリーパーっていうのは寝る人という意味なんですけど
一応スリーパーっていうのは枕木のことなんです
だからこの言葉の遊びがありますけど
ワンライフフォーワンスリーパーといえば
まあ寝てる一人の人には一人の生命がありますよ
で まあ当たり前なんですけどね
一人の人が寝ていて その人には生命一つありますよと
ライフ命一つありますよというのは当たり前なんですけど
だからその当たり前の言葉のカラクリで
ワンライフフォーワンスリーパーという記事があって
読んでみたんですね まあ一応これ
シンガポールから出していた
シンガポールのインターネットのところから出していたホームページでしたけど
読んでみたら この日本軍が行ってね
シンガポールもそこもあって
マレーシアいろいろミャンマーやらいろいろ戦略したことがありましたからね
そこでこのシンガポールからマレーシア通って
ミャンマー通って ずーっとインドまで線路を作る計画
軍隊を決めて それも半年
1年で終わり終わりにしたいんだと
言って こちら軍事的な力を持っていて
人を捕まえてみんな強引に仕事をさせちゃって
だから鉄砲を見せて仕事をしろと
その人々の国でしょ その国に入って
みんな強引に 男やら女の人やらみんな捕まって仕事やってくれて
食べ物はくれない 給料はない
これ過酷労働させたんだと
そこでもう 2日  1週間仕事しちゃって
みんなもう死んじゃうんだとほとんど
そこで狙いはまあ線路を作って
そこでインドを攻撃することなんですね
よくも考えるもんだから
インドっていうのは攻撃できるんでしょうかね
で そこでこのエンジニア的には何もエンジニアも何もない
川あったり 山があったり
ひどい道でしょ かなり巨大だから
膨大だから そこで有名なね
怖い橋ですか まあそういうもう作ってそのまま潰れるとか
だからあっちこっち木なんか切って
もうカットして持ってきて
そのまま植えて その上でもう橋を作ったりとか
そこでご飯も何も食べ物もない人々
だから死んだ人々の数をかい
数ありましたから それ書いて
これで線路のスリーパーで数えたら
まあほとんどそれぐらい人を殺された
死んじゃったと だからやっぱりそれ読んだところで
なんでこの国の人々は未だに日本を許してないかっていうことは
なるほど そういうことかと
やっとわかったんで 日本ではそんなこと言ってもいけない話でしょうに
日本人がそんな悪いことしませんと
そんな常識やと だからやっぱり非常識なんですね
それは日本人に言ってとんでもないことをしてしまったという気持ちも作らないでしょ
だから やっぱり向こうは未だにすごい悲しいんですよ
考えてみてください 自分の家に誰かが人が入ってきて
自分に命令してご飯作れよと
これはもう美味しくないんですよとかね
もっといいものを買ってこいよと
私はもうすき焼き食べたいんだからね
お前すき焼き作ってくれと
お金あるんじゃないか
銀行から降ろせと命令しちゃうとどんな気持ちですかね
自分の家に行って知らない人が
殺してやるぞと この人の国を選択するっていうこと
そういうことなんです
鉄砲を持ってるんだからといって
だからそういう世界戦争やら国々間の戦争は法律で認められるんですよ
逆に 日本負けたんだだからアメリカが戦争裁判を起こしたりして
もし日本とドイツが勝ったならば
もう向こう側が裁判で犯罪者やと決めるでしょうに
どちらが正しいんですかね
戦争にも法律はあるんだとか
あるはずがないでしょうに
だからこの世の中で常識というものはないんです
常識というのは単なる浮いてる言葉で
世の中でまるっきり常識がないんです
ただ浮いてるだけの言葉で
その時その時好き勝手に自分の好みを言ってるだけ
平和 平和というなら アメリカがいろんな国に爆弾落としたり
いろんなもうかれこれやっていて
今日もテレビで見ていたんだから
このあのベトナムの問題とかね
いかにホーチミンをバカにしたりとかね
原子爆弾まで落とすように考えたりして
関係ない国なのに 単なるアメリカのプライド
共産主義に対して対立しているんだと
結局 共産主義は自分で自然死しただけであって
アメリカ様のおかげで共産主義がなくなったわけじゃないでしょうに
共産主義はそれで自然死になっただけ
ただ そのために限りない我々は苦しみを味わわなくてはいけなかったんですね
だからそんなものは常識だと平気で言ったりする
ですから 仏教的な立場から言えば
世の中には常識はありません
常識というのは すべての生命が平和で豊かで
それぞれの寿命を全うできるような努力することなんです
だから自分の権利一つもなくなりませんよ
すべての生命が自分の寿命を平和で豊かで全うすることだから
だから私も万々歳で 皆様方も万々歳なんでしょうに
そういう生き方こそ常識であって
それ以外のものはすべて非常識でやってはいけないことなんです
しっかりしています 考え方は
仏教だったら だから この世の中でこれはどうですか
あれはどうですかとか
みんなまあいろいろ小さな質問したがるなるでしょ
そういうものは別にそんな大げさな問題ではないんです
まとめて 例えば今の女の子たちが
20 cm 40  30 cm ぐらいのものすごい底が厚い
あれ あれは非常識じゃないんですか？とか
どうでもいいんだ そんなことは
顔やら体を真っ黒にして勝手にすればいいでしょ
なんか鬼みたい もう唇はほとんどピンクでもないんですね
あれはもう白く もう青いピンク
浅い浅いね 白 白色に近いピンクで顔真っ黒
でも勝手に見えるんですね
すごい気持ち悪く見えるんですね
まあそれで本人たちの言葉は超格好でしょ
かっこいいでしょ 超かわいいでしょと
まあ逆なんですけど 気持ち悪くしょうがないんだけど
まあそれを我々の見方です
でももうやりたければ
それはそれでよろしいし
でもそれ認めるかないか
例えば その子供たちがもうあまりろくなものを食べてもないんだから
体力はない ちゃんと筋肉はついてない
歩けないんでしょう 歩き方を見てください
みんな非健康的な歩き方でしょ
こうやって僕みたいに背筋を伸ばして立てませんでしょ
みんな歩くて 私は見てるんですよ
みんなカニなんですね
横に歩くんです こうやって
これえらい迷惑なんですよ
道路が狭いし 歩くところは狭いし
その前 店の人々は全部品物は道路に出してるし
そこで自転車もそちらで行くでしょうし
そこで歩く人々はもうカニのやり方で横に歩いているし
迷惑もいいところですけど
何も言いませんだけど
なぜかというと みんなの体の構成はそうなってるんです
背筋を伸ばすことはできないんです
足も曲がっていて 腰も曲がっていて
筋が全部曲がっていて
だから姿勢に歩くと 左に左に左に行っちゃうんです
右に右に行っちゃう 右に行って
そちらのフェンスにぶつかりそうになっちゃうと
また右に左に左にだってそこで店にぶつかるようになっちゃったら
また だからメートル歩く歩くためには
やっぱりメートル メートル歩かなくちゃいけないんです
だから私が早く見えるんです
あんたすごい早いんだと
私が早くないんです ただまっすぐ歩くだけなんです
ですから その上もう竹馬に乗ってしまっちゃえば
だからそこを批判したければ
そういう立場で批判したってもいいんですよ
君たちの健康に悪いんじゃないかと
別に勝手にやったってもいいんだけど
もう若いしね 遊び盛りでしょうしね
だから遊んだっても これはもう楽しい
我々にとっても でもまだまだ先が長いでしょうと
私たちは腰が痛くて 足膝が痛くて
もうあなた方も年取りますよと
ですから まあ大人として注意しますけど
健康は今からしっかりとした方が後では楽ですよという風なぐらいのことを言っちゃえば
向こうは反対しません
なぜかというと けしからんなことをあんたやってるんではなくて
言ってないんだから 時々若い人をそう言ったっても反論します
我々は大丈夫 元気だからね
元気だから若いなら大丈夫ですよ
おばあちゃん 何かを言わなくたってもいいんですよ
と言ったら まあ言われる場合あります
私も言われる時ありましたからね
私はね 私も昔そう思っていたんだと
私の反応はただそれだけ
私も昔はね 絶対元気でもいられると思ってたんですと
それ事実だから 私も若い時は病気になりっこはないと思っていたんだからね
なんでこういうみんな病気ばっかしで
ああ かわいそうやなと
自分がもう何やっても全然もう何も病気も何もない
日本に来ても その時でもね
まあ年取ってから日本に来たんだけどね
日本に長いんだからね
最初は冬なんかもう平気で
もう雪の中でももう薄着で
みんな風邪引くぞ 風邪引くぞ
気をつけなさいとみんな心配してるのが
私はもう引くもんかと
引かないんですよ でも今は違いますけどね
この年になっちゃうと
まあちょっと違う 寒さはちょっと効くようになると
ですから まあ若者に あんた方はね
将来のことを考えたら
ちょっと反撃する可能性はありますけど
まあ一言で私もそう思ってましたよと
いえ まあまあ それで問題は解決するだけでね
まあやりたければやったってもいいし
ですから 一時的な社会のことは批判する必要はないんです
それは批判する時でも
このみんなの幸せ そのその個人の幸せ
そこを考えた方がいいんです
例えば 今の人々っていうのは
あまりこの真面目じゃない場合もあります
もう勉強よりは遊びの方がいい
特に女性のね 女の人っていうのは大変かわいそうと思いますけどね
遊びばっかしで で 一言言ったければ
じゃあ我々は死にますけど
それからの世界はあなた方の世界でしょうと
国の国会議員であろうか
総理大臣であろうが 会社の社長であろうが
みんなあなた方はやらなくちゃいけないでしょ
できると思いますかと
まあ向こうはね もういいです
できますよと その時我々のやり方でやるんだよというならば
まあしょうがないんです
国は滅びたっても ああ
そうですか じゃあどうせ我々は先に死にますからと
と言っちゃえば それで問題は解決する
そういうことで この常識というのは
私の立場から見れば 世の中にないもんなんですよ
だから私に言えるのは
この非常識な状態から脱出して
もっとまともな常識な人間になりましょうと
あります で 常識な人間になりましょうということを言いたいんですね
そこでこのまあ 他のポイントなんですけど
まあ私も宗教ですから
宗教の世界を見ると なんか非常識なことをいっぱいあるんじゃないかなとか
よくこのカルト宗教やらね
新興宗教やら見ると もうはっきりと見えるのは非常識そのものなんですね
それも で 社会に迷惑かける
他人に迷惑かける それは平気で正当化する
宗教の概念を持ってきて
ああいうのも非常識なんです
例えば あの日本の例を出しちゃうと失礼ですから
外国の例出しますけど
例えば神様は絶対なりだと信じる
神がすべて作ったと信じる
その神を守ることは我々の仕事だと
だから人の生き方は神の奴隷で
神を賛美して神を守る
褒めることですよと言って
神の方を向く 見る顔 人間に背を向く
それですごいトラブルを起こすでしょ
社会の中で このある宗教でこの原理主義という考え方ありまして
その神信心宗教でね 原理主義だから
神様が言った通りに 文字通りに実行してみるんだと言って
何のこともなく人殺したり
自爆ということもありますけど
自分で爆弾体に付けていて
どこかにも ある時はね
アメリカ大使館にね 車いっぱい爆弾つけちゃって
ずっと運転して大使館の中に入ってしまっちゃって
そこでもう爆発して その人も死ぬと
それで天国 人殺したりして
でああいう風に病気になったらどうしようもない
全く治る方法もないんですね
そうやって宗教の世界でももうもう非常識のいいところ
だから顔を人間に顔を見せてないんです
人間に背を向いて 一緒に生活している
一緒に生きている生命に対し
背を向いて神の方を見ている
そうするとみんなの幸せを壊すと
平和を壊せる 人殺しが起こりくる
起こる 争いが起きてくる
自分の宗教を信じる人と信じない人という 2つに分けちゃって
敵と味方に分けちゃって
結局血が流れているだけの結果になりますね
だから 知恵のある人は神がいるかいないかという馬鹿げた話ではなくて
我々の生きている世界を見ているんですよ
見たら今何が起きているかとお互いに殺し合いやっていることだけなんですね
信仰はどうでもいいんですけど
殺し合いはいいんですかと
インドネシアもそうでしょう
今はもう殺してるんですよ
もうキリスト教の人々
みんなもう全部もう何のことなく
村ごとに燃やしたりする
だから一人も常識な人間いないんで
国連にもいない インドネシアにもいない
どこにもいない 常識あればもう力強く下げるでしょうに
あなたはアッラー信じたければ勝手にやりなさいと
イエス イエスを信じたければ勝手にやりなさいと
人殺しするなよと 私たちに見えるのは
あんた方お互いに殺し合ってるだけですよと
殺し合え 殺せというふうなことを宗教の聖典に書いているんだったらいいですよ
そういうことを書いていないはずでしょうし
なのに平気でやっちゃうと
まあ日本でももう同じ
誰かが宗教作っちゃったら
また他の人は敵にして
まあ戦い戦い 喧嘩喧嘩ばっかしで
あれ何なのかで宗教なのかと
各宗教家の間で調和がないというならば
それ自体宗教家なる権利さえもないんです
キリスト教であろうが
仏教であろうが 浄土であろうが
何道であろうが 私にとって関係ないんですよ
なんで仲良くしないんですかね
自分の牛の方を見ているんですよ
私は浄土系だから 阿弥陀のところを見ているんだと
私は真言だから もう大日如来の方を見ているんだと
阿呆だから何見ていたってもいいんだけど
人類に生命に背を向くなということを言いたいんですよ
いくらなんでも阿弥陀さんがもう何も持ってく
おにぎり一個も持ってこないんだから
大日如来は何一つも持ってこないんだから
それは自分の母親やら親戚やら
そういう人々を一生懸命苦労して作っているんだからね
だから個人の信仰として阿弥陀様ありがとうございますとか
それは別に個人の自由ですからね
それは一向に構いませんし
あなた信じてないんだからといって
その人に当たることは何なのかと
ですから この宗教の世界でも明確に
この非常識もいいところなんです
人間の幸せ 幸福を作るために必要できたんだけど
経済学者にできないこと
政治家にできないこと
当時の王様にできなかったこと
が 宗教がやるんですよ
例えば法律で別にできませんでしょ
みんな心を落ち着けて生活しましょうとかね
怒ってはいけません 通り作ることできませんだからね
正直になりなさいと そんな法律できませんだから
それは宗教の世界で まあ充実感があって
幸せで 正直な心で 嘘をつかないで
平安な心で頑張ってくださいというところはね
まあそれは宗教がやる仕事なんですけど
その人々はよ常識破って人殺しまでする
政治家と組み組み合って戦争しながら宗教を広げる
世の中で今世界宗教だと威張っているこの大きな宗教 2つありますけど
あれ宗教は正しいんだから信じているんですかね
キリスト教とイスラム教なんですけど
それが一番大きい あれ正しいんだからじゃないでしょうに
殺しちゃったんだからでしょうに
人の国まで行って ああいうのも非常識なんですね
だからまあもう人が死んじゃってもあれ死んでないんだと
私が神様だからね もう何とかして生き返ることはできますよと言って
このミイラ現象も事件とかいろいろあるでしょうね
あんなものは話にもならないんだけどね
どれぐらい非常識かというと
まあですから 一応常識になりましょうということで
一部を話を終了して もうちょっと違う次元で二部をお話しさせていただきます
ちょっと 10 分ぐらい休憩いたします
どうもありがとうございます
常識は死んでいると 生きているのは非常識だということなんです
で まあ世の中 また俗世間の考え方になりますけど
まあ世の中を見ていると
いろんなことをね まあある時期でいいと思った
常識だと思ったことは
また時間経つと変わっていく
また時間経つとそれも変わっていく
一番わかりやすいのは女性の生き方なんですね
随分激しく変わっていくでしょ
昔の理想的な女性の生き方っていうのは
もうまるっきり今の女性の理想的な生き方とまるっきり違いますしね
服装もそうでしょうし
デザインやら髪型やら何から何までまあ違うでしょ
恐ろしく変わっていくんですね
だからどこに常識あるかと
疑問になってくるんですね
で そういうことで人を責めてはいけません
私はこういうもうわざと知っている上で
この過激的なことを喋っているんです
日本の社会ではそういうふうに言わないことも
そういう価値観ないことも知ってるんです
知ってるんだからといって
皆様の意見に合わせて喋って
まあいいお話でしたわということで終わりたくないんです
で そこで時々私にこう
まあちょっと自分に自信がある人々が時々言う時もありますね
このあの ちょっと日本はもう日本の価値観は違いますよと言うんだけど
私は認めない なぜかというと
日本の価値観って何でしょうかと
日本の常識って何でしょうかと
例えばものこのちょっとしたこの 50年の間で日本は変化したでしょう
どれぐらい変化したんですかね
江戸時代の人のことも
時々写真なんかでね 描いた絵とかね
版画とかであるでしょうに
あれも日本でしょ 正真正銘の日本人でしょ
今いらっしゃるのも正真正銘日本人でしょ
江戸のところの絵と今の日本人が同じですかね
今 日本で西洋的な背広を着ること
西洋のスカートを履くことは常識であった
だから完全に西洋化していることこそが常識であって
日本の伝統的なものを守るのは非常識になっているんじゃないんですか？古い方々以外は
誰もどこにも着物を着て来ないでしょうに
袴は俺は全然履かないでしょ
男性は結婚式以外は そういうことまでしながら
私に常識論は語らない方がいいんですね
だから食べ物はどうですかね
もう完全に西洋化しているでしょう
西洋化というか 多様化になっているでしょうに
でもそれは悪いと誰も言ってないし
私も悪いとは思ってないし
皆様も悪いとは思ってないし
女性は着物を着ようか
スカート履こうが ズボン履いていようが
別にどうったことないでしょうに
だから ある時期 子供たちがね
ピアス穴開けようと思っちゃったら
ものすごい混乱して もう大変なことで
えらいもう大騒ぎで まあそれを落ち着いてくると
今はまた違うことで大騒ぎしたりして
あんなものは暇人が大騒ぎして金儲けたっていいんだけど
知識人にとってはもう面白くない世界なんです
まあ放っておけばいいんです
そんなことで頭を困らせたりするのはもったいないんです
だから この人に無意味なことをして金儲かるという生き方だからね
だからマスコミやらいろんなもう余計に問題混乱させて
混乱させて 混乱させて
もうそれで金儲かってるんですよ
あんな不正的に金儲かったっても本当に悪いと思いますけどね
ですから この世の中で常識というものはみるみるうちに変わっていくんですね
これは世の中の論から言えばね
そういうものは私から言えばどうったことないんです
どうったことないです
であと 1ヶ月間でいきなり
まあ大体そういうことを破るのは若い人々だから
いきなり違うことを何かまたやっているかもしれませんだけどね
別にそんなことはまあ気にせんでもいいんです
自由に まあそれぞれ自由にやればいいんです
そういうことだから 特にお釈迦様の世界では
人はどんな服装を着るかとかね
どんなアクセサリーを授けるべきかとかね
そういうのは関係ない
考えてないんです だから仏教という宗教は表面で見られないんです
だから表面的に出す 見せよう見せようと思っちゃうと
まあそれはまあそんなに意味あることではないんです
やっぱり私たちは心の中身のことを考えているんだから
とにかくこの そういうものについて
あまり私は何も語りたくない
あの口紅はどんな色は正しくて
どんな色は正しくないとかね
これ質問しただけでも馬鹿馬鹿らしいでしょうに
私にとっては真っ黒の口紅したっても
全然そう暗い まあ黒いですね
それで終わっちゃうんです
それは真っ赤であろうが
真っ白く口紅塗ってみたっても
クリームホワイトでものすごい
もう色白いでやってみたら
別に私も何も気にしません
ですから まあそういうこのあまり問題にならないことは
あまりこのもう関係なく
みるみるうちに変わっていくんですよ
世の中で ですから それは世の中の変化で
だからそこは止まろうとするところ
あれは非常識なんですよ
この若者はいろんなことを発見したり
いろんなくだらんことをやったりする
まあ放っておけばいいんです
それは止まる 止まろうと思うところは
私は非常識だと思いますね
学校の行き方は変えるかもしれませんし
教える内容も変わってくるかもしれませんし
だから 例えば日本の教育システムはいろいろトラブルがあるんだと
それは改良しなくちゃいけないんだという意見だけは
日本のインテリの人々の間ではよくあるでしょ
あるんだけど 会議も作るわ
委員会も作るわ 何年も研究もしてレポートも出すわ
一向に一瞬でも前に進まないでしょ
入学制度はどうしましょうか？評価する制度はどうしましょうか
いろんなこと考えてるでしょうに
一歩も前に進めないんですね
あんまりにも頭が悪いんですかね
例えば今問題があるんだと
この問題はなんとかしなくちゃいけないということでしょうね
それなぜできないんですかね
それはこの 非常識なんです
それ自体 だから まず言葉が浮いてることをと
それからこの古い伝統も無意味であるにも関わらず守ろうとしている
だから教育 教育システムであろうとも
いろいろトラブルが起きているんだとわかっているんだったら
システムはじゃあ改良しましょうと
それできないということは
心はものすごくこだわってるんですね
古いこの死んでいるシステムに
だからそれ変えるのは
やがて子供たちがもう何て言いますか
暴動を起こして もう社会はむちゃくちゃにするところまでするところまでもう発展したら
なんとかしなくちゃというふうに起きてくるかもしれませんね
だから オウムの事件は日本で起きた事件で
世界で各国で瞬時にそれをもうストップしようという法律は瞬時に作っちゃったんです
この事件を起こした国でどうですかね
ためらうことっていうことは
やっぱり知恵がパッパッパッと出てこないんですよ
だから私は未だにあの問題解決してないと思います
なぜかというと 同じ日本の人々でしょ
いくらなんでもその人々にもこの国で生きる権利がある
どこかで住む権利がある
仕事をする権利がある
たまたま何か変な事件を起こしたっても
生きる権利は奪うことはできないでしょう
だからそこはちゃんと考えて
何か結論を出せばいいでしょうに
こちらに住むなと こちらからあちらそちらに住むなとかね
それでその人々はどうしますかね
なんで未だにあの若い人々はなんでいつでもグループ作って群がって
蜂の巣のような感じでいるんですかというと
そうでないと生きていられないんですね
麻原に消えます  1 日 100回ぐらい
もうあの 5回投じて なんとか投じて
あれやらないと生きていられない状態にしているんですね
だからグループで行くんですよ
一人一人でアパートなんとかで
どこかでアルバイトして
まあコソコソとオウムやったってもいいんだけど
それはできないんですね
もしみんな一人一人で自分でアパート借りてからったら
もう誰もわからないし
もうそれで普通の仕事をしていれば誰もわからないし
まあたまたまどこかで集まってコソコソと自分の宗教をやったっても
それは別に問題ないでしょうに
それできない それでもう 100人であろうか
200人であろうか みんな 400人だろうと一緒に共同生活したがる
そうすると日本人がみんなもう出て行け
出て行けと追い出したりする
そうすると そこを辞めるために法律作ったりする
一向に問題には答えがない
なぜかとその人々は浮いてる言葉でしか考えてないんですね
だから問題を見てないんですね
たとえ事件を起こしたっても
人間でしょうと 生きる権利あるでしょうと
その人々にも幸せで自分
自分の寿命を全うする権利あるでしょうということもあった上で
何かすぐ対策を講じるでしょうに
例えばあんた方はね 自分勝手な信仰は個人的なものだと
信仰っていうのは これは社会的なものではありませんと
国家的なものではありませんと
私は何を信じるかということは
私個人の問題であって
国家の問題ではありませんと
ご飯食べるかうどん食べるかということは
それは個人の好みであって
それは決して国家的なものではありません
ですから 個人個人で何を信じたってもいいんだけど
まあ一人一人で生活しなさいよと
他の宗教を見なさいよと
イエス様を信じている人々いっぱいいるでしょうにと
でもみんなそこをそこら辺で
自分自分で家を買ってそれぞれ生活しているでしょうにと
たまたま教会にたまたま教会に行って
そうやってメサをやったり
いろいろなことをやったりしている
でも誰も迷惑だと思っていないでしょうにと
でも キリスト教にしたっても
この信者さんたちがみんな教会で集めて
そこで寝泊まりして 生活しちゃうと社会問題でしょ
そうすると そうするとちょっと社会問題になりますね
時々そういう問題も キリスト教の世界でもできましたから
日本でできちゃったんだから
ですから そこら辺はなんとかその人々に独立できるように
まあなんとかしてあげたりとかね
誰か誰かがね ボランティアでもなんとかしてあげたりして
それからまあ悪いことは法律でできないように
法律でも作ってしまえば
もう何のこともないんですけど
やっぱりこの この古臭い
もうどうにもならない伝統を守ろうとする
問題を起こしているんだとわかっているにも関わらず守ろうとしているのは何なのかと
それは人間のなんかね
いけないところなんで
とにかく ですから この伝統
しきたり 習慣というのは常識ではないので
そんなものはさささささっと変えていっちゃうんです
みるみるうちに それで悪い結果が出してますよと思ったら
300年の伝統であろうがやめた方がいいんです
これは社会に悪いとわかったら
もう 300年のところじゃなくて
千年  2000年続いてきた伝統でも
すぐやめた方がいいんです
そういうのは非常識ではないんです
そういうのは正しい道なんです
それこそ常識なんですね
だから何かシステムを頑固で守ろう
守ろうとするのは非常識であって
どんなものも緩やかに変化していくんだと
それで我々の仕事は常識を守ること
いわゆる変化するのはいいんだけど
万人のために どんな生命にでも
自分に幸せで幸福で 自分の人生を全うできるようにと変化させましょう
今のシステムではちょっと無理があるんだったら
そのシステムを変えましょうと
で そういうことで ずっと常識を守る人に限って
社会は毎日毎日新しい方向へ
いい方向へ変化させることはできます
それできなくなっているのは
まあその常識死んでる方からなんですね
まるっきり非論理的な非常識だけに生きているんだからなんです
で 日本の経済システム
会社システムはいきなり変えなくてはならないのに
なかなか変えないんですね
そういうのはそこで見えるんでしょ
だから古い伝統 今までやってきたやり方
そこを守る守ろうとしている
一旦仕事に入ったら まあ退職するまで安定しているのは当たり前ではないかと 1
年に2回  2  3回 何て言いますか
あれはボーナスもらうのは当たり前ではないかとかね
そこはうまくいった時もありますけど
それでうまくいかない時も出てくると
じゃあ今の状況で我々はみんな幸せになるためにどうすればいいんですかといっても
さささっとシステムを変えた方がいいんですね
そういうインスピレーション
そういう能力は知恵と言うんですね
問題が起きたらすぐ答えが出ること
そのように心 心を育てなさいというのは仏教的な言い方なんですね
だからものすごいこのもう元気でないと仏教は無理
だからお釈迦様はこう言うんですよ
まあ元気でもなくてね
この教えは知識人の賢者のためにあって
愚か者には関係ないんだと
この教えは精進努力する人のためであって
怠け者には関係ないんだと
できませんよ ご実行は
で 10種類の根本会ですごい大胆な消すという言葉ですからね
その 2つだけでも覚えておいてください
仏教は何のためかと 誰のためかと
まあ 9番目に出てくるのは智慧を目指す人のために
愚か者のためではないんだと
そこで智慧というのはない人はかわいそうですね
そうすると ブッダがインテリの人だけ集めて
知識の知識人だけ集めて説法する
頭が悪い人々はあっち行きなさいと
ということになりますが
それはならないんです
なぜかというと 智慧の開発する方法を教えてあげるんです
それはもうただ育ててないだけ
育てればいいんです ですから
次にこの この常識破りというか
常識を守るというか 私にとってはおなじみなんです
常識を破ることも 常識を守ることも同じ意味なんですね
なぜならば もうとっくにみんなもう世の中の人々がね
もう非常識だから だからそれを破るということも常識になると同じことなんです
私にとっては で 生き方については私に聞かないでください
それはあまり関係ないことで
どんな服がいいんですか？とかね
どんなおしゃれの方が仏教的ですか？とか
そんなものはないんだから
で たとえ結婚について仏教はそういう立場なんです
奥さん2人もらうべきか
3人もらうべき一人ですかとかね
決まりがないんです 昔
ちょっと友達とちょっと喧嘩に喧嘩ではなくて話し合ったことがあって
で みんな遊んでるんですね
そこで私のことをあまりもうちょっと好きじゃないんですね
うるさいことを言うかもしれませんと
私は私にとってはね あんた方は何やっても関係ないんだと
だってあんたはお坊さんでしょうと
だから何ですかと あんた方は仏教のこと知ってます
あんた方知らないんだと
仏教だったら奥さん 10人もらっても別にどうったことないんだと
それはまあ 不倫にももうもうよくないこと何もなりませんと
で わからないんで そういう人
わからないのは当たり前なんですけどね
それは一人の男は一人の女と結婚する
するしなさいと決めたのはヨーロッパでしょうと
あんた方はそれを真に受けちゃって
アホだからね その通り
これこそ正しいだと思っただけのことであって
歴史的に人々の地球の歴史を考えたことがありますかと
いろんな国でいろんな習慣があったでしょうにと
で たまたまもう西洋の方が正しいと
それを認めるためには
我々は西洋のキリストの教えも神の教えも信じなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それはキリストの教えから出た話であって
それも聖書には根拠はなし
聖書では書いてない 一人の男は一人の女だけで結婚して生活しなくちゃいけないんだというふうには書いてないんですよ
そういうふうにどんどんどんどん伝統的になって
本当にただ当たり前で常識やと思ってわかる
覚えておくだけで理解しないんですね
理解するとそこら辺わかるはずなんです
だから ある文化で一人の男性が二人
三人 女の人をもらったりする
ある文化では一人の女の人が二人
三人男性をもらったりする
そういうふうな社会もありましたし
ポリガミー ポリアンドリーと英語の単語までありますから
だからそこで仏教の戒律はどうなりますかと
仏教というのは この社会で法的に認めている決まり破って
異性に対する欲を出しちゃうと
それはよこしまない行為だと
だから いかに普遍的な教えかと
だから今の社会の決まりは一人一人でしょ
だからそれは今社会の決まりで
それ破っちゃうと もう余計な欲を出していることなんですね
そうすると まあ戒律を犯したことになります
もし法律で女性にも二人の旦那さんをもらうことはできますと
男にも二人の女の人をもらうことできますよと法律で決めちゃったら
その人 仏教の戒律も破っているわけじゃないんです
法律でできるんだから
自分が二人の面倒を見ているんだと
そこで昔のいろんな社会で
この男たちは人殺しに行くでしょ
隣の国に それはいいわけじゃないんだけど
人殺しにあの国も潰すと自分の国のために行って
もう国を広げて来るそうでいて死んじゃうんです
そこでこちらで女の人々ばっかし
国の中に 男は数少ないんですね
そうすると 年の女の子がまあ 5人
あるいは 10人がいて
その村にもう結婚適齢の男は二人しかないとかね
だからどんな対策はいいんですかね
例えば10人娘さんがいるとする
若い男の子は二人しかいないと
そうすると その二人が自分好きな女の子を二人選んじゃったら
あの8人の人生はどうします？それであのじゃあ五人五人分けてもらいましょうと
もらって家族作っちゃえばいいでしょうに
それは別に何のこともないんです
それはそれでいいと私は思います
逆に男が多くたくさんいて
女の人が少なくなっちゃうとどうしますかね
今日同じことで だからそういう
そういうことさえも 一般的なこの口紅の色と同じことなんです
神が決まったものでも何でもないんです
口紅はどんな色にするかと
歯はどんな色の 昔の日本では歯はどんな色でしたっけ？綺麗な美人の歯は真っ暗でしょうに
真っ暗で何か塗っちゃうでしょうね
歯にも 今はあれは醜いんだというだけで
昔は綺麗なべっぴんさんですよとか思ったりするでしょうに
したでしょうにね だからそういうものはね
そんなに大したことじゃないんです
だから人間のこの思考をもうちょっと綺麗にしてほしい
問題というのをよく明確に客観的に考えてほしい
そうするとすごくもっと幸せな社会が出てくるんですね
例えば仏教では当然よこしまない行為をするな
それはあなた 自分の家族も不幸にするし
他の人に迷惑をかけるし
あなたも自分の感情のコントロールできなくなって
もう大変不幸になりますよという教えがある
それはその通り 常識なんです
それは故に 一人の男性は一人の女の人しか関係を持ってはいけませんというのはまた違うんです
それは誰かさんが勝手に決めたことであって
だからこの考え方っていうのは
このそういうふうなことで
いろんな新しい考え方いっぱい出るはずなんですよ
この こんな変な非常識に囚われてものを考えるんじゃなくて
正しい常識に基づいて物事を考えちゃうと
今はまあ 自分の国はもう結婚というのはしきたりもなかったんだけど
仏教だからちゃんと奥さんは旦那さんのことに忠人で
旦那さんも奥さんのことを大変大事に守ったりいたんだけど
数は決めてなかったんです
何人かと そこでもう植民地になったところで
もうキリスト教文化では一人だけですよと
君からまあそういう風になっただけ
だからそこは常識ですよと言ってほしくない
それは習慣だけ 一時的な決まりだけ
これから社会はどう変わるかまたわからないんですよ
日本でも女性の人口は多いでしょうね
おそらく おそらく多いと思います
自分の国だったらもう女性の人口が多いんです
大学でもどこを見ても女ばっかしで
もう仕事でも もう一体いくらいくるところでも女ばっかしなんです
裁判がやってるお裁判官もいるんです
女性の人口はまあ少々まあ結構多いんです
まあそうすると そう言っちゃうと
やっぱりそれなりに決まり変えないと社会は平和にならない
それでも伝統的な西洋の価値観は頑固と守っちゃうとどうなることをかと
結局不幸になっちゃうんでしょうね
そういうふうなことで
我々はこの常識を守るか破るか
どちらで言葉にしたってもいいんだけど
我々は常識守る 常識守ると思って
この古臭い何の意味もないしきたり
習慣を守ろうとしている
それは怠け者だから 問題理解できないんだから
新しいものにチャレンジするのは怖いんだからやってるんです
私の言葉では腰抜けだからやってるんです
それで社会は発展しないんです
悪いものはすぐできるだけ早く変えると
そこは常識なんです なぜかというと
みんな 1 日でも不幸になる必要ないんです
1 日も早く幸福になるべきなんですね
だから 今までやってくるシステム
習慣を変えるということには勇気が必要なんです
だからお釈迦様は 私の教えは勇気のある人のためである
精神できない弱者にはできません
と で そういうふうなことも言ってるし
じゃあ一応そこら辺はそういう話を象徴して
あの仏教は智慧の世界だから
智慧はどのように あの
この常識を破ることで
あるいはもう非常識破ることで生まれてくるかっていうことをね
そこら辺 ちょっとちょっとポイントを聞いたいんだけどね
まあ若い人々がいるんだったら
役に立つように喋りますけどね
で 例えば この これからの話は大体若い人に向きなんですけど
まあ他の方々にはなんか関係ないっていうこともあるかもしれませんし
あの  我々はいろんな問題に出会ったりするでしょ
それで困ったりするんですね
どうすればいいか どうすればいいかと
仕事の中でもいろんなもういろんな選択にはめられちゃって
どっちにすればいいかとわからなくなったりで困ったりする
よくあることは答えが出てこない
結論が出てこない どうすればいいかと
何でしょうかね そこは何かに引っかかってるんですね
学生であろうか 普通のサラリーマンであろうか
普通の若奥さんであろうか
毎日いろんな問題に出会い
ぶつかったりする ぶつかったところでどうしようか
どうしようか どうしようかとかね
悩んだり困ったりする
答えがすぐ出てこないということ
それは我々は何かに引っかかってるんですね
この引っかかってることは
本当によく見ると古臭い伝統なんです
よく見てください この古臭い伝統
古臭い伝統と言った途端
また誤解しないでください
これは ３００年古いか
２０００年古いかと 伝統は１０年でも伝統なんです ２
３年何かやり方 何かやってきたならば
それはもう伝統ですよ
もう定着しているんだから
だから定着している生き方
考え方 両方ともまあ伝統
トラディションなんですね
それに引っかかっちゃうと答えが出てこなくなるんですね
もう一つ前にも言ったんだけど
この問題自体 言葉自体が浮いてる時も決して答えが出てこないんですね
例えば会社にとってはね
まあもっと利益をたくさん出さなくちゃいけないんだと
もっと儲からなくちゃいけないんだと
もう頑張りなさいよと
そういう風に言われるとストレス溜まるばっかしなんです
なぜならば 利益出さなくちゃいけないという言葉は浮いている
もっと頑張りなさいという言葉は浮いている
あんた方はしっかりしないんだから
もう会社はもう大変危険だよと
これ浮いての言葉なんです
だから 言う側がマーケット状況をちゃんと計算して
ちゃんと理解して まあこれから １ 年は我々にはこれぐらいの利益を上げることができるんだと
これぐらい利益を上げることできるんですから
じゃああなた方はこれこれこれぐらい頑張ってくださいと言えばいいんですけど
そこでまたおかしくなっちゃうんですよ
ノルマつけちゃうでしょ
日本では そこまた浮いてるんですね
何の根拠もなしに これぐらい儲からなくちゃいけないと決める
決めて平気でこれ割ってみて
人の首の数で割ってみて
一人一人にノルマをつけたりする
それで大変なことになる
全て浮いてるんです だから
そういう極端的なところじゃなくて
いつでも実際の浮いてないところで物事を見ると
すぐ答えが出てきます
だから会社は今年はこれぐらいプロフィットを上げますよと決めるのは悪くないんです
でも この決めたシーリングというんですけど
英語だったら 決めたシーリングが具体的で合理的で実現できるものでなきゃ
ただの浮いてるだけ 例えば
もう次々収入はもう ３００億円にした方がいいな
これはいいなということだけでしょう
感情だけでしょうに そういう夢だけの話っていうのは浮いてる言葉で
そういうものに我々はすーっと責められちゃって
子供たちに勉強する時でも
全部浮いてる言葉で もうしっかりしなさい
よく勉強して もうもっと勉強して
シーリング決まってないんですね
シーリング決まってないんだから
これ大変にストレスになっちゃうんですね
ストレスになるんだからこそ
知恵が出てこないんですね
いくらやっても物足らなくなっちゃう
だから知恵が開発してきてければ
自分たちが何か希望 何か目的
チャレンジするものを作っても構いません
私はこうなりますと これぐらい儲かりますと
でもその作るシーリング自体が合理的で具体的で
実現可能なもので 今よりもうちょっと頑張れば実現可能なと
そういうところに作ってしまえば
日常生活の中でかなり知恵が開発してくるだろうと思います
そういうことだから このまあ伝統的にもうものすごい浮いてる言葉ばっかり喋る
感情的な言葉ばっかり喋る
感動する言葉だけ喋る
美しい言葉 並んで並んで並んで
もう喋ると そんな話術に騙されること自体も非常識なんです
よくあることは そうやって話術者に騙されちゃうんですね
だから 知恵が開発したければ
そういう相手が喋る言葉に意味があるかないか
浮いてるかないかと見てください
浮いてるんだったら 自分には答えが出なくてもいいんです
それが自分考えていること
自分の希望やら夢やらね
それは単なる浮いてる言葉か
事実に根付いているんですかと
ちょっとチェックしてみてください
浮いてる言葉だったら
ただの言葉の遊び それは言葉逆立ちに読んだり見たりする遊びと何同じことなんです
上から読んでも下から読んでも山本山やと
まあそんな風な まあ何のことでもないんですよ
人間がまあもう神の子ですよと
人間は仏様の子供ですよとかね
いろいろあるけど 全部浮いてるんです
何の根拠もないんです
で そうやってもいっぱい美しい浮いてる言葉ありますけど
そういうのはまあやめてほしい
で それからこのそれからではなくて
いつでもこのどんな言葉でも
我々は当たり前だと理解しようとするんですね
そこをやめた方がいいんですね
面白くないんです 言ってることわかってるんだと思うの
どんなものにもちょっとチャレンジしてみる
すべて当たり前だ 例えば嘘をつく
嘘つくなよと言った時とか
そうですねとか あんまり面白くないんですね
そうですねと認めるのは
そういう人はやってない
やらないんですよ 忘れちゃうんです
だからそれにチャレンジしてみるんです
なんで？このなんで？という
なぜという その一言葉
大変ありがたいもんなんですよ
嘘をつくなよと なんで？人に聞いたら失礼だったら
自分一人で なぜ嘘ついてはいけないんですかねとかね
真面目に考えた方が頭は違う方向に回転する
この決まりの中で行動すると頭は回転しないんです
特に日本みたいなしっかりこのもうシステムできている
あのもうきめ細かく物事を決まっている社会っていうのは
知恵が開発しにくいんです
生まれた時から死ぬまでもうやることはもう何だかんだも決まってるんですよ
挨拶の仕方やら 何上が何度体が回すべきかどうかね
どれぐらい頭下げるべきですかとか
こうやって全部マニュアル化になる
マニュアル化になることも一つの文化の発展の結果なんですけど
あの 例えば原始世界ではそんなことはないんだから
挨拶の仕方もないんだから
だから一応文化の発展の結果なんですけど
マニュアル化になってしまうと
人は考えなくてもいいということにもなりますね
だから子供たちの間でいろんな挨拶の仕方があるでしょ
大人だけこの頭を下げてやってますけど
例えば手で手と手ぶつかったりとかね
それも挨拶でしょうに
若い子はよくやるでしょ
ね こうやってお互いに手をパチンとやったりしたりとかね
握手でもなんでもないんだから
あるいは時々指一本こうやったりとかね
それも挨拶でしょうに
だからもう例えば自分が仕事に会社に行ったところで
課長にもこうやってパチンとやっちゃう
これまた何か考えるかもしれませんだけど
じゃあおはようと 私はそれでもいいと思いますけどね
もっと仲良くなれるんだから
それちゃんと あの 何て言いますか
こうやってきれいにして
おはようございます なんとなくちょっとまたかえってやりやすいんですよ
それで終わりだからね
問題は そうすると人間関係やら
もっと脳細胞に刺激がなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことだから このあまりにもこの
まあ我々は文化的な社会で生きているんだから
決まりはたくさんありますけど
そういうものはもう片っ端から破れということではなくて
自分一人一人でも どんなつまらないことであろうとも
もうちょっと考えてほしいんですね
昔のある小学生がね なぜ人を殺してはいけないかときいたところで
みんなびっくり どうしてそんなことじゃなくて
そういうふうにも考えるんだと
じゃあ我々のは答えられますかと
誰にも答えられなかったんだからね
恥ずかしいでしょうね
大人としては そういうことだから
この もうちょっと考えてほしい
そこはお釈迦様はわかりやすいことでこう言うんですね
昔から決まりやということは
あなたの知識の基準ではありませんと
これは昔から決まっているんだから
そうですか はい わかりましたと言ったら
自分が馬鹿になっちゃうんですね
昔からそういう決まりがあってもなくても
自分で新しく考えて それは理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
もう一つ 神の言葉だからといって信じるでしょ
世の中の人々は 聖書を見る
聖書に書いてあるんだからといって
私も脅されたことはいっぱいありましたからね
あんたね 聖書に書いてます
あんたそんなことやったら地獄に落ちるんだよとか
私は怖くなるだろうと思ってるんですね
この 2000年のローマ法のあれ
メサテレビで見たんだからね
あの神の子が生まれたんだよという文章を書いて
こうやってものすごい尊く持っていくんですね
だから何なのかと そこに書いたんだからといって
神の子が生まれたかないかは別な話で
だからって我々はそれをあ
参りましたと言ってね
神を信じなくちゃ全然思いませんだけどね
だから聖書に書いてあるんだ
神の言葉ということは
ある個人の知恵の道ではありません
自分で考えなくてはならないんです
そうすると すごい知恵が出てくるんです
聖書にあるものは全部その通りに信じなさいと言った途端
もう知恵が消えてしまっちゃうんですね
それからよくあることで
世の中で何かこの論文を書くときによくあります
いろんな人の本から引用するんですね
何々さんがこう言いましたと
また何々さんがこう言いましたと
そうやって我々はテキストに弱いということがあるでしょ
そこですごいかっこいい論文を書く人は
たくさんの人々の話を
調べて調べて調べて並べて書いておく
あれ格好悪いんですよ
例えばエイブラハムリンカーンがこう言います
だから何ですかね ケネディ大統領は
まああれ 何でしたっけ？アースノット
ワットユー ワット ザカントリーハズダンフォーユー
アースワットユー まあなんとかありますね
国が自分に何をやってくれるんではなくて
自分が国のために何がやってくれるんですか？と聞くとき
あれは単なる作家 そういう人々が書いた美しい文章だけなんです
それでもうしゃべるだけ
だからなんですかと だからそうやって人のもうすごい偉い立派な名言というものをとかね
それからテキストにあるものとかね
引用して持ってくると
我々ははっ まいりましたと思うだけで
自分の知恵にそれでもって刺激入りますかと
例えば ケネディがあんなことを言ったんだけど
ケネディさんが本当に何かやったんですかと
アメリカ人がないんだから平気で言いますけどね
結局戦争したばっかしで
キューバに対しても原子爆弾でも落としてやろうとか
ソ連に対とか そういうところまでやっていたんだからね
言ってることやってることは
もうだからなんで口先で言う言葉だけ
言葉だけいくらでも並べるでしょうに
私にも言えるでしょうね
皆様方は立派な方々だから
日本のみんなのために頑張らなくちゃいけないと
世界を救済しなくちゃいけないんですではないんでしょうかとか
世界の平和を願ってみんな頑張ってください
でもできますかね そんなこと
言うぐらいはいくらでもできますから
だからこのテキストやらいろんなところやらね
引用して我々を脅してやるぞというふうな世の中で
そういうものも私個人の知恵の基準ではありませんと
自分で考えなくてはならないと
時々あの もう私にも時々聞こえるんだけどね
あ 先生はこう言いましたからと
先生はそう言いましたからと言って
そんな鵜呑みにしてはいけません
私が何か言ったんだからといって
そのことは本当にその通りですかないかと
やったらそういうふうないい結果になるか
あるいは悪い結果になるかと
その個人で判断しなくてはいけないんですね
でお釈迦様はだいたい言うのは
この私 ブッダがそう言うんだからといって信じる必要はないんだと
なぜ信じる必要ないかと
自分の知恵ではありませんだから
だから他人の知恵でもいいんです
他人の知識でもいいんです
それは自分で判断して自分のものにする
そういう働きで知恵というものは発達していくのです
テキストを持ってきて
何かメモを書いて持ってきて
そこを読み上げると 例えば私の話で言ったら
私は誰の話にも引用してないんですよ
こういうテーマで 仏教のテキストっていうのはものすごい膨大な量があります
私は本も持ってないんです
今日も一つの経典からちょっと引用を
みんなにご紹介しようと思ってコンピューターで調べようと思ったところで
コンピューターももうそのまま停止しちゃった時ももう動かなくなっちゃって
それでやめちゃったんです
見ている途中でもういきなり止まってしまっちゃったんです
まあそれはしょうがないんですね
ということで だからテキストいろいろある
だからといって 別にそこからあの人こう言いました
この人こう言いましたとかね
やっぱり言ってることは自分の知恵で知恵になる必要があるんです
だから私が言うことは決して私の知恵ではありません
私もお釈迦様から借りたものですけど
お釈迦様から借りて教えていただいて
それから自分の知恵にする
そうすると自分でもう語れると
もう一つ この悟りの世界
仏教ではこの涅槃解脱ということがあるんですね
なぜ人には涅槃解脱できないかというと
とことんこの束縛されているんだからよと
何に束縛されていますかね
世の中のこと 価値観の問題で
価値の問題で だからそういうのは一つ一つ破って
いい方向へいい方向へ持っていかないと
ただ単に修行したんだからといって悟りっこはないんです
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
この涅槃というその教示さえも
そういうこの人間の非常識をとことん破って
究極的に一番幸せを見つかるということなんです
世の中にあるのは非常識で
人々は不幸になる道だけですよと
結局 もうどういうふうな生き方を生きていたっても
あまり発展は見られません
同じところでぐるぐる回っていると
みんなに合わせるだけの人生だから
社会に合わせるだけの人生だから
同じところで回っているだけなんですね
たまたま食べるものは変わる
着る服が変わる 住む家が変わる
まあそれぐらいの変わり方なんですね
乗る乗り物が変わっていく
でも人はそのまんまで
逆に科学的な乗り物は発展しちゃうと
家を張って家が発展するとどうなるかというと
人間の能力がなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば 自分の家はインテリ的な
そういう計画もありますからね
家を作ると このコンピューター技術を駆使してインテリビルにするんだと
そうすると外の温度を計算して
自動的にカーテンを開けたり閉めたりする
空気の温度をちゃんと計算して
クーラーやら暖房やら自動的に調整すると
人がお風呂に入る時間は決めて
お風呂が自動的にオンになってお湯を沸いていると
会社から人が部屋に来る時間
電話でか何かの方法で家に連絡すれば
家の機械に だから家についてる機械が
この人は 9時半に来るんだと
だから私が 30 分前に暖房を入れちゃえば
この人が部屋に入ると 23度に入ってるんだと
自動的に暖房が動くとかね
そういうふうなことを考えたり
別に不思議な技術ではないんだけど
簡単にできるもんですけど
ケチだからまだ作ってないだけで
で 技術的にはそんな難しいことではないんだけど
そうなると人はどうなるんですかというと
アホになるんですね なぜかというと
自分がカバン持って玄関から出て出ていけばいいんです
出て行ったところで ドアが自分で閉めて
自分で鍵をかける 夫人が出て行ったんだからということを知ってるんだから
コンピューターが全部
窓の鍵もカチンカチンカチンとロックすると
そうすると人がいないんだから
余計なところの電気は全部自動的に消えていくと
そうすると そこに住んでいる人は何しなくたっていいでしょうに
自分が部屋に部屋に入ると
そこに玄関に自動的に明かりがつくと
部屋に入ったら そこは自動的に明かりがつくとというふうに
こんな面白い話なんですけど
逆にこの生命体として
一人の人間としての能力は全部消えていっちゃうんですね
そういうふうにいろいろまあトラブルもあります
ですから 私たちはこの機械を発展するんであって
自分を発展させないんですね
だから無知な質問ではなくて
私が言いたいのは自分を発展してください
だからどちらか共同的なところあるんですよ
機械も人間に必要です
人間っていうのは弱いもんだから
ね 我々は肉を食べたっても
例えば牛を捕まえて噛んで食べることはできませんだから
ライオンにはできますけど
だから人間は機械作って牛を殺して小さなスライスにして
焼いたり煮たりして食べなくちゃいけないんですから
そこまではいっぱい機械を使わなくちゃいけないんだけど
だからといって機械の奴隷になる
だから今の人間の生き方っていうのは
道具のために生きている人生なんですね
だから道具は偉くて そこをどんどもっともっと考えるんです
人間らしく考える 人工角を持っているロボットとかね
そこまで考えたりする
だからそういう方向は
そういう人々は遊びで考えるのは
私はまあ否定も反対もしませんだけど
自分の成長 自分の発展
自分の心の発展も見なきゃ意味がないんですね
わかりやすい 死ぬ時は買ってるコンピューターロボットを持っていかないんですよ
死ぬ時は自分の心だけだからね
そこは原始状態で死んじゃうと
と意味がないんです ですから
とことんこの心の成長というものは必要なんですね
心に刺激する 与えることは必要なんですね
だから 何でも何でも伝統的にものを認めちゃうと頭は回転しないんです
だから仏教はどこまで智慧開発するために物事を言うかというと
私はよく瞑想を教える時はいう例えがありますでしょ
バラの花を 1本持ってきて
このバラの花はきれいですよというのはダメだと
あれは今までの決まりだけであって
どういうわけでバラの花はきれいですかと
それは事実だと思ってるんですかと
そうやって考えてほしいんですね
だから常識的やと思って
我々はある伝統に引っかかっちゃって
誰かさんが決めた決めた決まりなんですよ
バラの花はきれいということは
それでみんなそう その通りでございます
バラの花は綺麗ですと
それは事実ですと そう思って
その上で思考を持っていくんですね
あれはダメなんです ちょっと考えちゃうと
これは人間だけ思うことで
バラの花綺麗っていうことは
それまた各人間にとっては
バラの花に対するアプローチはそれぞれ違うでしょうし
ですから 花を見て心の中に作る感情っていうのは
何の根拠もない いい加減でしょうと
私はよく言うのは 例えばある若い男の人が赤いバラの花 1本持って行って
自分気に入っている女性にあげたと
あげたところで厳しい言葉でね
あなたにはもうしゃべりたくも来ないんだと
放っておいてくださいと
私はあなたのタイプ あなたは私のタイプじゃないんだと
あなたの顔を見るとムカッとするんだと何とか言った
言われたならば まあそういうことを女性
は言いますけど 男は言いませんだけど
まあまあ言われますよ
ひどいこと 言われたならば
その男の人っていうのはかなりこのもう精神的にはデリケートだから
かなりショックを受けちゃうんですよ
それでその人に同じ赤いバラの花 1本見せちゃったら
ああ綺麗という感じが生まれますかね
生まれないでしょうに
すぐなんとなく気持ち悪くなっちゃうでしょうに
自信がちょっとなくなっちゃうでしょうに
だから何か見て作る感情っていうのは
そのその人の勝手であって
何の真理性もないんだと
聞く音にすぎても 何も真理性はないんだと
それは私にとっては面白い
故に全ての人類にとって面白いと思わないこと
そういうふうに この真理の世界に持ってくると
すべての固定概念を破っていかなくちゃいけないんです
そこで戦争も起こりません
例えば ある音楽を聴く私にとっては
私が感動する 私がバカだからあんたも聴いてみてください
これすごい感動しますよと
そこら辺からおかしいんです
時々どうでしょう どうせ面白いでしょう
面白いでしょうと もうそうやっても押し付けまでするんですね
そこでその人は面白くないと言ったら
なんだこの人はと またもう仲が悪くなったりする
だからそういう心理的な構造だからこそ
世の中で逆らいという戦いやら対立やら全て起きてくるんですね
それより逆に 自分がある曲を聴いたところですごい感動しました
そこでちょっと実験として
試しに誰かさんにもあんたこれちょっと曲を聴いて感想を言ってくれませんかと
言った方が正しいでしょ
この曲をちょっと聴いていただけませんか？と
どれどれどれ その人は何のことなく
何のマインドコントロールなく聞くでしょうに
聞いたところでどうですか？あなたは
あなたの気持ちはと聞いたら
その人はやっぱりこれ感動しますと言ったら
だって私も感動しましたよと
それだけで終わります
故にこの曲は感動する曲と言ったら
もうそこでおかしいんですよ
3人の人は感動しないかもしれません
だから 3人目の人は だから物に対する好き嫌いやら
もうなんだかんだで感動するかしないか
怒るか怒らないかとかね
そういうものはあくまでも主観の世界で思って起きてくる幻覚であると
そういうふうに このもう限りなくすべての概念の世界をね
破って真理の世界に行くんです
そこに悟りという究極的な幸せがあるんです
何にも囚われない 何にも誰にも変化できない心の平安がそちらにあるんです
いろんなものに囚われている我々には心の平安がないんです
こだわりがある限りは
そういうことだから この
涅槃というそのものさえも
こういう常識破りというか
一般人の非常識破り そういう過程の結果から生まれるものなんですね
私たちはヴィパッサナー瞑想だと思って教える方法も
もう瞬間からのこの思考の伝統的なパターンを置いといて
何も新しいものを教えてあげないで
マインドコントロールもしないで
ありのままにこのファンクションの機能を見てみなさいよと言って
本人に発見できるようにする
だから この 私に最近言われた言葉
あなたなくてもヴィパッサナー瞑想を教える人々いっぱいいるんだよと
私も反論したかったんだけど
私は一度も教えたことはないんだと
あの で言ったんだけど
言わなかったんだけどね
まあ一応ヴィパッサナーの世界でも瞑想指導者がいません
もし誰かが私は瞑想指導者というならば
それはまあ違うかもしれませんだけど
本当にヴィパッサナーを教えている先生方というのは WE
help others to help themselves という言葉なんです
他人にをどう言えばいいんですか？それは日本語で
どう言えばいいんですか others
to help themselves ということ
彼ら自分自身でやることを助ける
違う違う その意味じゃない
他人が自分自身でやることを手伝う
I help you to help yourself ということは
どう訳すればいいんですか？ あなた自身でやることを手伝う
I help you というのは
私はあなたを助けてあげるということでしょ To
help yourself
あなたがあなた自身を
あなたがあなた自身を助けることを
私が  助けて 自分のことを自分でできるように
自分 私は手助けをするということ
だから自分のことを自分でするんです
自分で努力して自分で悟れるんです
他人が教えるんじゃなくて
ほんのちょっと助けてあげるだけ
ですから このヴィパッサナーの世界では
先生たちは全然威張らないんです
人が修行してそれなりに成功すると
ああ よく頑張りましたと
相手が頑張って あなた頑張っていい結果を出したんではないかと
ああ よかったと 私が教えたんだからということは成り立たないんです
本人が頑張らなかったら何にもなりませんだから
だからそれは仏教の世界なんですね
だから救う 救済というのは全然ないんです
我々にとっては毒なんです
あんな言葉さえも 人を救うと
ありえないんです 人を救済すると
ありえない あんな毒の話なんですね
人は弱くする 助けてくれという気持ちになる
でも仏教の世界では助けてくれと言ったら
やっぱりあんた悩んでるんでしょうと
だからあなたはこういうこういう風にすれば
自分で自分のことを助けられますよと
だから 生命は平等なりということは
仏教は厳密に守るものなんです
それも浮いてる言葉ではありません
いわゆる実感なんです
誰かに生かされていますか？我々は
結局は自分勝手に生きているでしょうに
人いうことは聞くんだけど
そういうのは本心ではないんです
聞かなかったらまずいんだから聞いてるだけなんです
旦那さんが奥さんに言うことを聞く
奥さんも旦那さんが言うことを聞く
でもまあ実感としては自分が自分で生きているという実感あるんでしょうに
それはわざと否定して生かされているんだと
というとまた良くないし
生かされているということは悪い言葉じゃないんです
これ違うところでいい言葉なんです
この場所はちょっと変えてもらわないと
いわゆる自分勝手に威張って生きていこうと思ったってもできくはないんですから
すべての生命の組み合わせによって生きているんだから
そのポイントを見て生かされているんだというのはいいんですけどね
そうやってこの悟りということさえも
一切の固定概念を破ることから生まれるのであって
それは決して悪い恐ろしいことではありません
ですから 仏教は微かな迷惑も社会にはかけません
そういうことで話を終了したいと思ってます
で まあとにかく智慧を開発してくれるように頑張ってください
どうもありがとうございました